notre émission spéciale continue gros
plan sur le ramasse que je vous propose
maintenant organisation financement
soutien étranger adhésion des
Palestiniens on en a parlé ensemble
pendant quelques minutes on va
décortiquer le fonctionnement la
stratégie du mouvement terroriste avec
nos experts mais tout de suite les
premières explications de Jérôme
Rabier mouvement de résistance islamique
voici le nom officiel derrière
l'acronyme du Hamas organisation
politique dotée de sa
et quiige de fa la bande de Gaza depuis
plus de 15 ans son chef Isma V en exil
au Qatar d' il a revendiquer les
attaques sur Israël dès les premières
heures du jour samedi
matin le cycle des in et des révolutions
dans la lutte pour la libération de
notre terre et de nos prisonniers qui
croup dans les prisons de l'occupation
doit
sach une revendication et unea d'leur la
radicalité du mouvement fondé en 1987
comme la branche palestinienne des
Frères musulmans le Hamas a toujours
refusé de reconnaître le moindre droit
aux Israéliens rejetant notamment tout
accord de paix contrairement à
l'Autorité palestinienne basée à ramala
et dirigé par une autre faction le fata
pour le Hamas Israël n'a pas le droit
d'exister nous ne pouvons pas
reconnaître la légitimité de
l'occupation de la Palestine ou
reconnaître
Israël qui tient donc d'une main de fer
la bande de Gaza depuis 2007 sur place
il fait la loi collecte taxe et impôt
lui permettant ainsi de financer sa
guerre contre Israël sa branche armée
les brigades eedin alkassam affichent
régulièrement son arsenal sa richesse il
la doit aussi au riches donateurs Qatar
et Iran en tête comme le reconnaissait
sans détour son chef landagne je
remercie ceux qui ont fourni des
financements et des armes à la
redoutable rés
la République d'Iran n'a jamais été
frugale avec la
résistance avec de l'argent des armes et
des
techniques ces dernières années les
pourparler avec les autres factions
palestiniennes ont repris pour tenter
d'unifier le front politique palestinien
mais à pour l'instant le Hamas
revendiquant toujours une Palestine
unifiée de la Méditerranée au Jourdin
selon la formule préféré de ces
militants alors que l'Autorité
palestinienne tenue par le fata et un
Mahmoud Abbas vieillissant et vu comme
trop conciliante avec leur ennemi juré
Israël je pr tout de suite mes invités
Isabelle lasser bonsoir bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes correspondant
diplomatique au journal Le Figaro Xavier
Guignard bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
politiste spécialiste de la Palestine au
centre de recherche noria Roger carucci
bonsoir bienvenue à vous premier
vice-président LR du Sénat sénateur des
hautes scènes et membre de la commission
des Affaires étrangère signale que vous
êtes également président du groupe
d'amitié France Israël Isabelle lasser
je commence avec vous parce que vous
aviez une interview Ismaël anier le le
chef du bureau politique du Hamas
c'était en il y a 6 ans c'est ça pour la
revue je crois que c'était en 2018 ou
politique international donc ça fait un
peu moins que ça 5 ans que cherche son
organisation à remettre la question
palestinienne au au cœur des débats et
en ça c'est malheureusement réussi oui
mais à l'époque c'était pas à l'époque
c'était pas exactement le même Hamas
parce que le Hamas était très affaibli
parce que les tunnels par lesquels les
les militants pass avaient été
détruits l'Égypte les Frères musulmans
en Égypte
était tombé donc le Hamas était dans une
période en fait où il voulait essayer de
retrouver une espèce de de
respectabilité peser en Europe et anier
à l'époque se présentait comme
pragmatique donc on était pas du tout
dans la même configuration
qu'aujourd'hui il y a eu une dériveah
depuis il y a eu plusieurs guerres avec
Israël depuis il y a eu la
radicalisation de netanahou et il y a eu
le le le très grand affaiblissement de
de l'Autorité palestinienne et puis
aussi un changement considérable de
d'environnement mondial donc il y a
plein de choses qui font que le le le
anier d'aujourd'hui n'est pas forcément
le même que celui qu'il était en en 2018
à l'époque il avait si je me souviens
bien essayé de d'assouplir euh certaines
certaines
positions
d'effacer euh légèrement l'antisémitisme
de du Hamas et cetera euh Xavier
Guignard le le le Premier ministre
israélien a promis d'éradiquer le Hamas
alors on a évoqué dans dans la première
partie du débat bon la la difficulté de
de tenir ce cette cet engagement mais
quand même il y a est-ce qu'il y a pas
un côté je sais pas quel terme employé
mais suicidaire dans la stratégie du
Hamas en tout cas en ce qui concerne les
personnalités de sa direction politique
et militaire c'est certain ils se savent
condamné à courte ou moyenne échéance à
une mort certaine ils vont être la cible
des représailles
israéliennes mais ça peut être dans un
mois Mo ça peut être dans 10 ans quoi de
toute façon absolument euh on a une
longue tradition du côté israélien sur
ces questionsl et et je pense qu'il y a
pas le moindre doute dans la tête des
dirigeants du Hamas après éradiquer le
Hamas et éradiquer un mouvement
politique et son soutien ça ça rend
beaucoup plus périlleux la réalisation
de cet objectif stratégique pour Israël
éradiquer les cadres c'est apporter
militaire d'Israël éradiquer le Hamas
c'est une question politique c'est
savoir euh est-ce qu'on est capable
d'effacer non seulement ses militants
mais aussi ce qui représente au sein de
la population palestinenne et ça c'est
un enjeu qui dépasse très largement les
questions militaires Roger kouci depuis
plusieurs jours on se demande comment
Benyamin netaniaou et même ses
prédécesseurs ont pu laisser le le Hamas
grandir alors que vous nous avez dit il
y a la question de même s'il y a eu une
évolution sur l'antisémitisme mais enfin
dans le programme il y a éradiqué le
l'État d'Israël al ça depuis les
origines le Hamas ne cache pas que sa
seule volonté c'est détruire l'état
d'Israël et même parce que on dit ah il
y a netaniaou donc est-ce que ça c'est
pas un peu durci mais quand Shimon Perez
ou euh itrac Rabine étaient au pouvoir
le ramas avait la même charte la même
volonté de détruire l'état d'Israël
d'ailleurs très clairement moi j'ai
quelques souvenirs de déplacement euh
dans cette zone euh certains responsab
Palestiniens plutôt du Fatar il est vrai
disait que avec eux on pouvait négocier
pour arriver à une solution à deux états
pas avec le ramas qui de toute façon ne
voulait pas entendre parler de deux
états c'est é pour eux strictement un
État palestinien et la disparition
d'Israël donc est-ce que les Israéliens
auraient pu empêcher le ramasse de de
grandir de de j'en sais rien parce qu'en
fait c'est très compliqué le ramass a le
soutien de l'Iran il a le soutien du
Qatar financier militaire ils l'ont dit
et reconnu d'ailleurs après si on disait
non plus rien ne rentre à Gaza et Machin
on aurait dire bah voilà donc on empêche
la la la le le fait de gouverner le le
le secteur de de Gaza moi je pense qu'il
y a beaucoup de responsabilité et qu'en
réalité le ramas qui n'est que quelque
part le bras armé de l'Iran refusait
absolument les accords d'Abraham refuser
de voir l'Arabie Saoudite se rapprocher
et que c'était le meilleur moyen
d'empêcher tout ça c'était de durcir les
choses éidment on en reparlera un petit
peu plus tard Matthieu au-udelà de
l'empêcher de grandir est-ce que le
Hamas si je peux me permettre
n'arrangeit pas aussi les affaires de
netaniiaou c'est quelque chose qu'on
entend il l'a laissé prospérer parce
qu'il avait en en face de lui du coup
une un pe un peu l'ennemi
idéalousir projet CACI et puis ensuite
vous pourvez prendre la parole à
Monsieur les je suis pas sûr moi j'ai
rencontré plusieurs fois puisque
évidemment dans les échanges rencontré
le Premier ministre donc netaniaou après
que j'ai rencontré s ses
prédécesseurs je pense qu' en fait le
gouvernement israélien ne sait pas quoi
faire avec le ramas c'est très compliqué
quand les discussions avec les
Palestiniens du Fatar ou avec Mahmoud
Abbas c'est toujours compliqué mais mais
on peut se parler qu'est-ce qu'on peut
discuter négocier avec le ramas qui dit
mais de toute façon je n'ai rien à vous
apporter je veux vous détruire donc bon
c'est un peu compliqué quoi mais votre
avis même question je reprends la
question de non oui tout fait enfin moi
depuis le nombre d'années que je vais en
Israël selon les gouvernements il y a
trois grandes menaces qui sont toujours
citées c'est soit la menace nucléaire
iranienne soit le hzbollah soit le Hamas
et alors après ça change en fonction des
gouvernements mais ce sont les trois
menaces consid comme existentiel auquel
fait face Israël et c'est beaucoup de
menaces pour un très petit pays et je
crois que c'est très compliqué enfin le
le Israël frappe régulièrement enfin là
c'est la destination du du hzbollah
frappe des convois régulièrement mais
c'est c'est très compliqué la réaction
internationale à chaque fois qu'Israël
frappe part comme ça comme une comme une
étincelle euh on est dans un
environnement qui est extrêmement
volatile c'est c'est pas facile de se
débarrasser de de de du Hamas
x Guignard Benjamin netaniaahou
voulait-il vraiment s'en débarrasser
alors ces derniers jours on a des images
qui ressortent ou des citations de
Benjamin netaniaou qui aurait voulu
privilégier le Hamas dans ses jeunes
années par rapport à l'OLP ou au fata
pour faire un contrepoids je suis pas
certain aujourd'hui que ça soit la
meilleure grille de lecture ce qui je
dirais deux choses la première c'est que
du point de vue de l'établishement
sécuritaire israélien la et ou politique
la question du Hamas et plus largement
de Gaza était moins une question ces
derniers temps que l'effort était mis
sur la S Jordanie sur la protection des
colons avec d'énormes détachements
militaires qui étaient envoyés là-bas et
avec l'idée derrière que le Hamas avait
trop à perdre le Hamas avait trop à
perdre parce qu'on lâcher un tout petit
peu sur des permis de travail sur l'aide
qui vient on a parlé du Qatar je
différencierai l'aide qui arrive du
Qatar à Gaza elle est sous supervision
de l'ONU avec l'accréditation d'Israël
elle vient en quel elle vient payer les
salaires des fonctionnaires oui donc il
y avait cette idée que cette question
était une non question qu'elle pouvait
qu'elle était mise sous scellé et qu'on
pourrait y revenir peut-être un jour
plus tard là c'est une prise de
conscience et puis là le deuxième point
et peut-être pour pour aller un peu plus
loin une des façons de répondre au au
Hamas c'était peut-être d'avancer avec
ce que proposait l'autorité palissienne
le point mort des négociations et et
c'est pas mes paroles c'est celle de
martinendck l'ancien envoyé spécial
américain le la mort des négociations
c'est la poursuite de la colonisation je
pense que la la réponse politique qui
aurait pu être apportée au Hamas et à
son projet ça aurait été de valoriser ou
de favoriser le projet d'en face et ce
qui n'est plus le cas depuis maintenant
une dizaine d'années alors je voudrais
qu'on parle de de de cette opération de
cette ces attaques terroristes sont les
brigades eeddin alkassam qui ont qui les
ont mené on parle de plus de 20000
combattant c'est difficile évidemment
d'avoir une source directe et et
totalement fiable mais c'est le chiffre
qui qui circule le plus communément
Isabelle lasser que sait-on des jours
des semaines qui ont préparé ces ces
attaques terroristes bah là il y a
encore il y a encore énormément d'ombre
et notamment une des ombre c'est à quel
degré l'Iran au point de vue étatique
est vraiment un impliqué dans l'histoire
euh jusqu'à quel point le hzbollah aussi
qui a augmenté sa coopération avec le
Hamas depuis plusieurs années euh était
au courant et euh ça je crois que ces
zones d'ombre ce qui est certain euh
c'est que l'opération était planifié de
longues dates euh qu'elle a euh qui a
fau quand même de de de de très gros
moyens militaires et financier alors
c'est vrai que depuis euh quelques
années la la puissance en armes du du du
m c'est c'est à gonflé avec les aides
fournies par par l'Iran à la fois des
aides financières à la fois des aides en
matériel alors là on on on peut-être
qu'il y a eu des aussi des instructeurs
du hbollah qui auraient participé à à
l'opération tout ça pour l'instant n'est
pas confirmé mais le Hamas aussi ces
dernières années avait réussi à obtenir
une capacité de production locale avec
des ateliers dans lesquel il fabriquait
des drones des missiles et cetera donc
c'est vrai que la la puissance militaire
du Hamas à et politique a vraiment
grossi en plusieurs années mais donc on
en revient à la question Roger k ça ne
pouvait ça ne passait pas inaperçu ça ne
pouvait pas passer inaperçu oui mais
quand vous dites ça euh moi je comprends
hein c'est sûr que les services de
renseignement israélien qui ont failli
la semaine dernière mais il y a quelques
mois ou quelques années ne n'était pas
en faillite donc il savaient les choses
on vous dit bah il multiplie les gade
ils sont armés par
l'Iran il y a des convois qui passent
par la Syrie qui reviennent en réalité
vers Gaza qu'est-ce que vous faites vous
bombardez systématiquement Gaza et
aussitôt les gens vont dire comment mais
qu'est-ce que c'est ça pourquoi il
bombarde Gaza alors que le Hamas à ce
moment-là n'a pas d'action terroriste en
Israël c'est incompréhensible que vous
bombardiez Gaza s'il y a pas d'action
terroriste donc en période de paix il y
a pas de raison de bombarder Gaza et
période de guerre on vous dira surtout
ne bombardez pas gaz donc on en revient
à la question de la solution politique
dont dont vous parliez tout à l'heure le
chef de ces briillat terroristes
s'appelle Mohamed da c'est lui qui a
annoncé l'opération déluge d'alaxa dans
un message vidéo c'était samedi matin
Xavier Guignard est-ce qu'il est devenu
le en quelque sorte je mets beaucoup de
guillemets au mot héros mais le héros de
la rue
palestinienne on peut mettre beaucoup de
guillemets il est devenu c'est certain
l'une des grandes voies palestiniennes
de ces de ces derniers jours il était
pas si connu que ça en dehors de des
militants du Hamas il est devenu euh
porte-parole de cette cause à défaut
personne d'autre ne s'exprime aucune
autre parole n'est attendue ce qui m'a
frappé c'était de se rendre compte le le
dédain qu'il avait le manque d'attention
à la prise de parole qui a pu être celle
de Mahmoud Abbas et ça traduit non pas
l'échec du Fatar et de l'autorité samedi
matin ça traduit son échec les 15
dernières années incarner un projet
politique incarner un horizon politique
à réussir à transformer ses prises de
position euh en succès et en ce sens le
Hamas a rempli un vide absolu oui et ça
veut dire que avant même ces attaques
terroristes le Hamas enfin palestinien
ég Hamas c'est c'est c'est je je je
schématise tout à fait volontairement
mais dans la perception euh du grand
public c'était est-ce qu'on peut faire
ce est-ce qu'on peut faire cette
simplication absol non je comprends
votre question euh le Hamas c'est
plusieurs réalités on l'a dit c'est
d'abord l'autorité gestionnaire de Gaza
et en ce sens elle est tout à fait
détesté au même titre que l'autorité les
palestiennes en si Jordanie est détesté
pour son comportement autoritaire pour
sa répression pour sa corruption puis le
Hamas et c'est la l'ambigué la
complexité de C comp c'est aussi là une
figure de ce qui est pour les
palestinens la résistance à l'occupation
israélienne et cette il est l'unique
figure puisque le le fata et l'autorité
palestienne ne sont plus reconnus par
leur peuple comme incarnation de cette
résistance de cette d'être en mesure de
défier l'occupation alors dans son
discours lundi soir benam net a comparé
le ramas à DAEs à l'état islamique on
écoute le Premier ministre
israëlien cette guerre nous a été
imposée par un ennemi abominable des
bêtes humaines qui célèbrent le meurtre
des femmes d'enfants et de personnes
âgées nous n'avons pas vu les atrocités
commises par le Hamas depuis les
atrocités de
daesh des enfants ligotés qui ont été
exécutés avec le reste de leur famille
des jeunes hommes et femmes qui ont été
abattu d'une balle dans le dos exécuté
et d'autres atrocités que je ne décrirai
pas
ici Isabelle lasser est-ce que cette
comparaison vous la reprenez à votre
compte est-ce qu'effectivement les les
massacres notamment perpétrés dans les
dans les kibuts rappell des méthodes de
de DAEs elle rappelle les méthodes de
daesh mais pas seulement elle rappelle
aussi les méthodes de Vladimir Poutine
en Russie ce sont exactement les mêmes
les mêmes méthodes il y a pas de il y a
pas vraiment de de de de de supériorité
d'un côté d'un côté ou de l'autre alors
évidemment au niveau politique les
discours ne sont pas les mêmes et les
guerres ne sont pas ne sont pas les
mêmes quoi que et là je pense que c'est
aussi très important à souligner
c'està-dire quand on dit qui est
derrière le le Hamas ok le Qatar l'Iran
ou mais euh moi je pense qu'il faut
aller bien au-delà et que ce qui est en
train de se passer en fait il faut le
mettre en parallèle avec la guerre en
Ukraine qui a révélé en fait des
nouvelles fractures dans le monde et la
constitution de deux blocs un bloc le
sud global qui lutte contre la
démocratie l'Occident et qui veut casser
l'ordre international de 1945 et un bloc
inverse qui est composé de la Russie de
la Chine de l'Iran de la Corée du Nord
parfois de la Turquie et qui euh a des
ramifications et dans ces ramifications
aujourd'hui il y a le hzbollah et le
Hamas et tous ces gens se tiennent quand
même la main alors il y a des intérêts
nation il y a des intérêts de de de
chaque pays par exempleiran il était
évident que l'Iran veut briser les
accords d'Abraham et empêcher l'Arabie
Saoudite de se rapprocher à son tour
après le Maroc Bahrain et les Émirats de
l'état de l'État d'Israël la Russie a
bien sûr un intérêt très clair c'est
d'éloigner en fait laattention
internationale de la guerre en Ukraine
mais tous ces gens-là ont quand même se
se rejoignent sur un agenda qui est de
chasser les Occidentaux de partout hein
d'Afrique du Moyen-Orient de l'ancienne
urss et de de d'imposer un un un un
ordre international différent et en cela
on peut pas il y a ces guerres sont en
mêlé évidemment c'est pas le même c'est
pas le même agenda politique là c'est un
agenda islamiste et Poutine c'est plutôt
un agenda taro communiste impérialiste
mais il y a il y a quand même une
intersection il faut aussi le voir
globalement parce que nous ça nous pose
un problème très grave et euh on peut
pas se laver les mains de de de ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui en Israël parce que
je pense que c'est le combat aussi de
toutes les démocraties occidentales
Roger kucci vous êtes d'accord ah ou je
suis assez d'accord en fait quand on
regarde d'ailleurs les prises de POS il
y a des moments un peu d'étonnement mais
étonnement fin hein pas pas de vrai
étonnement j'ai vu par exemple la
déclaration du président Maduro du du
Venezuela sincèrement on se demande ce
qu'il vient faire là et il est tout à
fait dans la ligne du ramasse et cetera
alors
que pe dire c'estàd les États qui
contestent
euh ce que sont les valeurs de liberté
de démocratie à
l'occidentale se retrouve souvent dans
les mêmes coalitions ils n'ont pas
forcément les mêmes intérêts locaux mais
ils se retrouvent souvent dans les mêmes
coalitions
l'Iran à se prétend l'un des phares de
l'islam mais en revanche comme il y a un
accord avec la Chine pas un mot sur les
Ouigours et en Iran pas un mot sur les
Ouigours parce que il faut pas déranger
l'accord sino iranien je je voyais que
l'Iran d'ailleurs disait clairement
qu'il soutenait tous les
mouvements de révolte un peu partout
dans le monde peut-être commis une
petite erreur par rapport à l'Arabie
Saoudite en citant le Yémen ce qui n'a
pas forcément dû plaire à Riad mais
Bonou ça c'est leur problème je je
voudrais qu'on revienne sur sur ces
informations concernant les les
massacres perpétrés notamment dans les
dans les kibuts c'était l'information
principale de de la fin d'après-midi
hier avec ces questions Mathie sur la
qualification de ces crimes actes de
terrorisme crime de guerre crime contre
l'humanité quel mot employer quelle
qualification connaissez la phrase de
Camu he mal nommé les choses c'est
ajouté au malheur de ce monde là en la
matière au-delà de l'horreur qu'on a
tous constaté des massacres de samedi
des juristes c'est vrai travaill sur la
façon de les qualifier alors d'un point
de vue juridique on va le dire au
téléspectateurs les crimes contre
l'humanité les crimes de génocide les
crimes de guerre sont définis et
recensés dans différentes conventions
traité et il rent tous de la Cour pénale
internationale alors les crimes de
guerre d'abord sont des violations du
droit international humanitaire la
Convention de Genève par exemple ils ont
toujours lieu lors d'un conflit qu'il
soit un conflit armé hein je veux dire
qu'il soit international ou non et ils
comprennent évidemment le meurtre la
torture le pillage le mauvais traitement
de prisonniers de guerre l'assassinat
d'otage l'attaque de population civile
la destruction délibérée de ville ou de
village ou encore l'usage d'armes non
autorisées comme les armes à
souousmunition ou les armes chimiques
les crimes contre l'humanité eux sont
des crimes commis dans le cadre d'une
attaque généralisée ou systématique
contre toute population civile et là
encore on peut trouver le meurtre mais
aussi l'extermination la déportation
l'esclavage la torture le viol les
évidemment les toutes formes de de
violence ou d'esclavage sexuel et à
l'inverse du génocide auquel je vais
venir les crimes contre l'humanité ne
visent pas obligatoirement un groupe de
population en particulier al ensuite il
y a la question du génocide qui elle
obéit à une intention de détruire tout
ou partie d'un groupe national ethnique
racial ou religieux considéré comme tel
alors ça se matérialise là aussi par le
meurtre l'atteinte grave à l'intégrité
physique ou mentale d'un membre de de
membbres du groupe la soumission à des
conditions d'existence devant entraîner
sa destruction physique donc des camps
par exemple des mesures visant à entrava
les naissances ou encore le transfert
forcé d'enfants et la question sétait
posé vous vous souvenez pour les enfants
qu'on avait vu se transférer d'Ukraine
en Russie alors il a déjà la question
des preuves qui qui AR voilà alors d'ors
et déjà le Haut Commissariat des Nations
Unies au droits de l'homme affirme qu'il
existe des preuves évidentes que depuis
le début donc c'està-dire depuis le 5
jours des crimes de guerre ont pu être
commis des deux côtés par le Hamas
évidemment lors de l'attaque samedi mais
aussi euh par lors des frappes
israéliennes de de l'armée à Gaza et le
terrorisme alors c'est plus compliqué le
terrorisme parce qu'il existe pas de
définition juridique universelle du
terrorisme c'est un sujet politique sur
lequel les États-membres de l'ONU ne
sont pas tous d'accord le droit français
est défini le terroriste comme une
entreprise individuelle ou collective
ayant pour but de troubler gravement
l'ordre publque par l'intimidiation ou
la terreur alors j'ai regardé la
définition en gros ce qu'en donne le
Conseil Scientifique du futur mémorial
du terroriste qui doit avoir le jour en
2027 et le résume aussi en gros l'acte
terroriste renvoie à l'utilisation
délibérée de violence disproportionné à
des actes asymétrique parfois présentés
comme ceux du faible au fort déclenché
par des entités généralement organisées
et clandestines visant à susciter on y
retrouve une terreur collective le tout
en pouvant choisir des cibles indirectes
pour renverser un ordre légal intimider
au entraindre un gouvernement un régime
une nation à céder à ses revendications
et atteindre un objectif politique et
idéologique que lui seul juge légitime
c'est un peu un peu compliqué mais ça
traduit bien en gros la définition que
les scientifiques en non et là force de
constater que ce qui s'est passé samedi
ben colle à cette à cette définition on
rappelle que le Hamas d'ailleurs qui a
revendiqué de nombreux attentats
suicides et d'actes de terrorisme depuis
sa création figure sur la liste
d'organisations terroristes de nombreux
pays occidentaux et on conclut en se
disant pour pourquoi le choix des mots
est si important parce qu'-udelà de
leurs conséquences juridiques le choix
des mots il est évidemment politique le
terrorisme ind des auteurs et des
victimes c'est un peu plus compliqué
avec les crimes de guerre puisque les
crimes de guerre surtout quand ils sont
constatés des deux côtés et ben d'abord
contextualise la violence c'est la
guerre c'est affreux et puis permet de
renvoyer éventuellement les belligérants
dos à dos merci Mathie sur ce thème
cette toute dernière information cette
fin d'après-midi la ministre français
des français des Affaires étrangères
estime que les attaques commises par le
ramass en Israël ça ente à des crimes
contre l'humanité était interrogé chez
nos confrère de France Info votre avis
Roger kucci parlez-vous également de
CRIM contre l' comme ma question au
gouvernement tout à l'heure après avoir
rappelé la formule d'Albert Camu j'ai
demandé à ce qu'on dise crime contre
l'humanité au moment de
daesh la communauté internationale à
l'époque Russie
comprise avait qualifié de crimes contre
l'humanité les crimes de daesh les les
décapitations la
soumission la mise en esclavage des des
yazidis et cetera donc là est-ce qu'on n
pas dans le même le la même idée je veux
dire y compris ensuite avec cette espèce
d'utilisation sur les réseaux sociaux la
décapitation
d'enfants on voit pas c'est c'est pas un
acte ni militaire ni rien qu est enfin
franchement vous décapitez pas un gamin
ou un bébé c'est voilà donc je pense que
la définition de crime contre l'humanité
devrait être
retenue je ne suis pas sûr pour être
tout à fait franc que ça aura beaucoup
de conséquences pour le responsable du
ramas parce que bon euh je je vois pas
un procès dans l'immédiat de la Cour
pénale internationale pour les membres
du ramas donc voilà mais la définition
doit être reprise et je apprécie le fait
que la ministre des Affaires étrangères
se rende à cette position qui est
d'ailleurs celle du président Larcher
qui a défini ce matin alors vous on a
commencé à évoquer le le rôle de l'Iran
en soutien du Hamas alors on va rentrer
un peu dans le détail et je vous propose
d'écouter sur ce thème le porte-parole
du Département d'État américain
l'équivalent de notre ministère des
Affaires
étrangères l'Iran soutient bien sûr
depuis longtemps le Hamas en lui
apportant un soutien matériel et
financier mais nous n'avons encore rien
vu qui puis suggérer qu'il ait soutenu
ou était à l'origine de cette attaque
nous examinerons d'autres renseignements
dans les semaines et les jours à venir
afin d'éclairer notre réflexion sur
cette question notamment pour savoir si
certains membres du système iranien
avaient une idée plus claire de ce qui
se préparait ou s'ils avaient même
contribué à certains aspects de la
planification Xavier Guignard pourquoi
cette question de la de la preuve elle
est elle est cruciale elle pourrait
justifier d'éventuels représailles on
est donc quel contexte là
elle pourrait justifier des représailles
politiques ou ou ou militairees il est
très difficile pour nous aujourd'hui
d'être en mesure d'en juger concrètement
on peut avoir des suspicions on peut
avoir des indications mais
rappelons-nous quand même que jusqu'à
samedi matin aucun d'entre nous n'avait
prévu ce qui allait se passer
aujourd'hui on est pris s un déluge
d'information les Américains ont assez
vite fait savoir qu'effectivement ils
avaient pas de preuve tangible de leur
côté et on est dans la propagande de
guerre les Iraniens rappellent qu'ils
ont absolument rien à voir même s'ils
sont très heureux de ce qui se passe HM
euh en ce qui nous concerne la la la
question c'est de se demander
oui on sait qu'il y a euh soutien
militaire soutien en terme de de
formation collaboration aucune des
parties de la caché vous avez repris les
déclarations du Hamas tout à l'heure
est-ce que le le Hamas agit là comme
simple proxy au profit d'un agenda
iranien ou est-ce que on lui reconnaît
des motivations liées à la situation
dont il est issu alors évidemment c'est
peut-être la déformation d'un
spécialiste de cette région mais j'ai
commencé quand même comm à penser que un
Gazaoui va pas nécessairement mourir
pour les accords d'Abraham mais
peut-être plus pour la la la situation
quotidienne qu'il y ait derrière une
exploitation politique par les parrains
de ou lesou les alliés du Hamas c'est
absolument certain aujourd'hui je n'irai
pas jusqu'à dire qu'ils ne sont là que
comme porte lance d'une d'une autre c
est-ce qu'il y a pour vous une influence
étrangère on en parlit dans la première
partie de cette émission qui disait mais
c'est pas un mode opératoire classique
pour pour le Hamas c'est plutôt des
chose qu'on a pu voir chez daesh avec
ses actions et sur réaction et
anticipation voilà ou de djihadisme
est-ce que vous trouvez que ce que ce
qui s'est passé samedi ne colle pas avec
ce que faisait le Hamas jusque- là et
que il a pu être influencé ou entraîné
par quel par par d'autres vous savez
depuis samedi et puis depuis 15 ans
quand on travaille sur ce ce conflit on
est confronté à des images qui qui sont
nettement
insoutenables au tout début samedi on
était tous choqués par la qualité
opérationnelle du Hamas sans aucune je
de valeur sur ce qui s'est passé et sans
sans renier les crimes qui on ont
découlé mais la capacité à mobiliser par
les aires terre et
mer a a surpris tous les commentateurs
militaires puis très vite sont arrivé
les images de massacre qu'on a pu voir
hier soir je me suis retrouvé chez vos
confrères de BFM à les commenter en
direct en sortant de là y compris
l'armée israélienne attendez on n'est
pas certain de ce qu'on a vu on a vu des
horreurs on on est encore en train de
qualifier ce qu'on voit donc il est
important pour nous sans minimiser ce
qui est en train de se passer de prendre
le temps de d'avoir des informations qui
sont confirmé je crois que ce midi le
correspondant sur place du monde Samuel
foret disait je les témoignages que je
recueille ne recoupent pas exactement ce
qu'on a eu hier donc on est face à
plusieurs questions d'un coup la la
l'augmentation de la capacité militaire
du Hamas elle est évidente et puis euh
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé dans ces
villages dans ces kibuts qui est
derrière ça c'est ce que je rappelais
hier et je vais continuer à le rappeler
il y a eu 29 points d'ouvert à Gaza des
milliers de personnes en sont sorties on
sait que la décision militaire elle a
été prise à priori dans ce qu'on appelle
la champ des opérations communes qui
regroupe tous les groupes armés de Gaza
et il y a des civils qui sont sortis euh
le lien qui est fait aujourd'hui et
qu'on peut complètement comprendre dans
dans sa prise de position de l'armée
israélienne entre ses crimes commis et
le Hamas c'est normal aujourd'hui on
sait qu'on a des milliers de gazaou qui
sont sorti on sait pas qui exactement
est allé dans ces villages le temps de
l'enquête nous le dira ce qui est
certain c'est qu'on a devant nous des
crimes de guerre prouvé avéré euh et et
quant à savoir si c'est une changement
de doctrine du vous savez jusqu'en 2005
le Hamas avant avant de avant de le
stopper commettait des attentat suicid
euh à l'époque on avait les mêmes débat
pour qualifier ce qu'il faisait donc le
changement pour moi ce qui est le plus
impressionnant et encore une fois je le
dis avec toute la prudence et les
délicatesse qui fait qu'on ne remet
enfin on ne minimise pas ce qu'on a vu
c'est son changement d'échelle militaire
on va parler de puisqu'on est autour des
soutien de du du Hamas on va aborder la
question financière maintenant grâce à
Marion Vig qui doit être juste derrière
dans les coulisses de de sens public
rebonsoir Marion on la question à
laquelle vous vous nous vous répondz
c'est la question du financement du
Hamas oui alors alors déjà selon le
magazine économique américain forbe le
Hamas est la deuxè organisation
terroriste la plus riche du monde
derrière l'État islamique mais quand on
parle du Hamas il faut rappeler que ces
trois composantes une branche armée un
mouvement politique et une entité
administre qui administre la bande de
Gaza et à ce titre on sait que le Hamas
reçoit à des fonds chaque année
notamment du Qatar avec un transfert
d'argent qui se fait sous supervision de
l'ONU et d'Israël pour éviter justement
qu'il y ait des détournements en 2022 le
Qatar a versé 360 millions de dollars
d'aide notamment pour payer les salaires
des fonctionnaires mais le soutien
financier le plus important aux
Palestiniens de Gaza mais aussi de 6
Jordanie reste celui de l'Union
européenne avec un budget de 1,2
milliard d'euros entre 2021 et 2024
après avoir envisagé de suspendre cette
aide après les attaques de ce weekend
l'Union européenne entend juste revoir
cette aide au développement en France
certains élus républicains comme ériic
cioti demandent l'arrêt des aides tant
que la preuve qu'il n'y a pas de
détournement au profit de la branche
armée du Hamas n'a pas été établie et
alors on a évidemment longuement parlé
de l'Iran autrees source d'aide majeure
oui et selon un un rapport du
département d'État américain qui avait
été produit en 2020 le régime des Mola
verserait 100 millions de dollars par an
au groupes palestiniens dont le Hamas
les États-Unis qui disent avoir la
preuve que le régime de téran finance
équipe et arme le Hamas ce que niit à ce
jour l'Iran la Turquie est également
dans le viseur des États-Unis accusé
elle aussi de financer le Hamas que
rejette enkara qui parle d'un soutien
purement euh politique on sait
d'ailleurs que plusieurs personnalités
euh du groupement palestinien sont
exilés en Turquie enfin euh le
organisation se finance grâce à la
fiscalité via les impôts mais aussi les
taxes des produits importés notamment
d'Égypte depuis 2018 le président
président égyptien autorise à nouveau
les échanges vers Gaza et chaque mois le
Hamas récupérerait ainsi 12 millions de
dollars grâce à ces taxes sur les
marchandises importé d' merci Marion
Isabelle lerre est-ce que les
Palestiniens voient une grande partie de
cet argent leur échapper à cause de la
corruption ah écoutez euh ça je
préférerais laisser cette question
euh oui à Xavier Guinard qui connaî h
euh quand Mme mieux ce domaine que moi
euh moi je par contre je je je
m'exprimerais bien sur le fait que en
fait l'aide de l'Iran elle est elle est
elle est financière bien sûr mais il
faut absolument replacer ça dans dans le
contexte de de l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien qui est euh mort depuis que
Donald Trump l'a quitté et que les
Iraniens l'ont violé euh complètement et
euh aujourd'hui la situation est quand
même extrêmement inquiétante parce qu'on
a un IR un Iran qui est quasiment enfin
qui est au seuil nucléaire h euh et qui
en fait cherche à avoir grâce à la bombe
nucléaire une espèce de de de dô de
protection dans tout le Moyen-Orient où
il pourra faire avancer ses pions et ses
proxis que sont le hzbolah et le Hamas
et les autres factions palestiniennes à
son bon gré pour pouvoir euh à la fin
contrôler tout cet axe chiite et c'est
le but de l'Iran et donc il faut aussi
replacer ça dans ce contexte parce qu'il
y a eu il y a quand même une enfin moi
je je suis cette histoire d'accord
iranien de d'accord nucléaire iranien
depuis à peu près 20 ans et il y a quand
même eu une une des des des tensions
entre entre Israël et certains pays
occidentaux Israël à un moment disant un
jour il faudra passer la le le le le la
vitesse supérieure et peut-être
peut-être qu'on devra frapper les
installations nucléaires iraniennes
sinon c'est tout le Moyen-Orient qui va
passer euh au cont sur le contrôle de
l'Iran et on ne pourra même plus parce
que vous comprenez quand vous avez la
protection de l'arme nucléaire vous ne
pouvez même plus faire comme les
israéliens font aujourd'hui c'est-àdire
aller taper les convois qui traversent
la Syrie et qui amènent des armes au
Hamas et et et au Hezbollah et
l'histoire a été pour l'instant enterrée
parce que notamment parce que les
États-Unis ne sont pas fanat de de cette
histoire mais c'est tout ça qu'on remue
aujourd'hui c'est tout ça qui est aussi
qui se joue en ce moment h Roger cuchci
dans dans les l'enjeu ou l'enjeu de les
enjeux de ces prochaines semaines il y a
éviter cette cette contagion à d'autres
pays de la région si on parle de
diplomatie du rôle de la diplomatie
française ou de la diplomatie américaine
par exemple oui moi je pense que entre
guillemets l'Iran pense avoir réussi son
coup
euh parce que ça va être très difficile
même si l'ambassadeur israélien nous
disait ce matin
que le gouvernement israélien essaie de
maintenir un lien avec l'Arabie Saoudite
évidemment avec le Maroc les Émirats et
cetera mais tout le monde comprend que
c'est très difficile et que même
l'Arabie Saoudite qui qui voulait aller
vers
l'accord va attendre de voir ce qui se
passe à Gaza va attendre de voir comment
on sort de tout ça avant de bouger donc
est-ce que l'Iran si euh l'Iran obtient
le fait que les accords d'Abraham avec
en tout cas avec l'Arabie Saoudite ne se
conclu pas est-ce que l'Iran va pas
considérer que son principal rival au
Proche Orient qui est en réalité
l'Arabie Saoudite n'est pas sur le coup
décalé et donc arrêter les choses je
vois pas l'Iran s'engager militairement
dans le conflit ils peuvent évidemment
actionner le hzbollah parce que ça c'est
plus simple et ça donnera un front nord
dans les opérations mais l'Iran lui-même
n'ira pas n'ira pas au combat surtout
maintenant que les États-Unis ont
déployé un porte-avion et et des
armements assez clairs sur sur la
Méditerranée orientale personne va aller
faire joujou pour pour voir si on peut
se frotter aux États-Unis dans dans
cette affaire mais on ne sait pas on ne
sait pas alors l'ambassadeur
israélien était convaincu qu'en réalité
après cette phase qui peut durer
plusieurs semaines on verra
bien la négociation renégociation des
accords d'Abraham reprendra parce que il
y a des éléments de fond mais bon on
verra vous vous disiez Xavier tout à
l'heure que c'était pas forcément
l'agenda du du ramas torpiller ses
accords d'Abraham je rappelle ça date de
2020 et vous nous avez donné la la liste
des pays qui s'y étaient déjà engagés
Maroc Bahrain Soudan et émirats Arabe
Unis et l'Arabie Saoudite qui était dans
un processus de de de normalisation
c'est l'effet collatéral en quelque
sorte moi c'est la lecture que j'en fais
à à pour deux raisons la première celle
que j'ai rappelé je pense que l' c'est
d'abord plongé dans ses racines
palestienes le second c'est qu'une
opération comme ça c'est des mois si CIT
des années de planification l'annonce
des
discussions saoudiennes entre Israël et
l'Arabie Saoudite sont finalement assez
récentes que ça participé à un élément
de déclenchement peut-être que ça soit
une victime collatérale c'est sûr mais
effectivement après 2020 les
Palestiniens ont assez peu bougé et
finalement il y a eu assez peu défaites
ces accords d'ailleurs les Émirats
arabes unis ont essayé par tout moyen
depuis 2020 d'attirer d'autres pays
arabes dans dans dans ce train de
normalisation parce qu'il se sentaiit
isolé et il trouvaent en tirer assez peu
de Bénéfic alors je connais pas le
contenu exact des négociations entre
l'Arabie et Israël on connaît un élément
qui est publié par la presse américaine
régulièrement c'est que l'Arabie
Saoudite voulait le feu vert américain
pour construire sur son sol des
centrales nucléaire à destination civile
mais c'est souvent le premier pas vers
du nucléaire militaire ce qui était pour
l'instant un feu rouge américain mais on
voit bien que le l'intérêt saoudien là
il était à travers ce rapprochement dans
un gar très national euh voilà quelques
éléments que que je peux apporter sur
cette question un dernier élément sous
forme de de témoignage ou de coup de
colère celui du président du groupe
Union centriste au Sénat cet après-midi
Hervé Marseille qui cible le rôle du
Qatar et de l'Iran l'écoute ces tueurs
ils sortent pas de nulle part ils ont
été accompagnés ils ont été aidés
entraînés financé et on sait par qui on
sait par qui par le Qatar puisque le
chef des tueurs éit berger au Qatar
monsieur anier est au Qatar cela même
qui finance ici le PSG ou d'autres
grandes
entreprises et
puis et puis il y a l'Iran et nous avons
été très conciliant vis-à-vis de l'Iran
dans le dossier nucléaire en particulier
pour rechercher des solutions parce que
nous pensions que c'était important pour
la paix dans le monde et pour la région
je voudrais qu'on termine sur le Qatar
Isabelle lasser on a beaucoup parlé de
l'Iran quel rôle le Qatar peut jouer
dans les dans les prochaines semaines
par exemple s'il y a des discussions des
négociations autour du sort des otages
alors le Qatar s'est fait une une
spécialité de de de médiateur hein il y
a plusieurs pays comme ça depuis
quelques années la Turquie en est un
l'Arabie l'Afrique du Sud le Brésil a
essayé et Qatar a pas mal a pas mal
réussi
euh il faut attendre de voir euh c'est
c'est c'est c'est difficile d'être un
médiateur quand vous êtes en partie mêlé
au dossier euh en même
temps pourquoi pas enfin je crois qu'il
est un petit peu tt pour en parler par
d'ord falloir attendre 10 jours que
l'offensive terrestre israélienne parte
donc je pense que la question pour
l'instant est prématurée oui même si on
a on a on a on l'a dit hier on l'a dit
dans la première partie il peut y avoir
en parallèle même si c'est le temps de
la guerre il peut y avoir en parallèle
des discussions qui s'amorcent oui c
pasop non non je je crois que c'est trop
tôt je crois que c'est trop tôt euh
c'est c'est c'est et en plus on a on a
trop de questions qui sont sans réponse
notamment sur
l'implication de de de
l'Iran c'est ça me paraît ça me paraît
trop tôt mais en théorie oui le Qatar a
montré qu'il était assez doué dans dans
dans le soft power diplomatique et
sportif oui pour puisqu'il nous reste 30
secondes et vous n'avez pas répondu à la
question tout à l'heure mais c'est
normal elle était plutôt destiné à
Xavier Guignard la question de la
corruption on parle de cette Man qui
vient du du Qatar pour l'Autorité
palestinienne enfin pour les
Palestiniens d'ailleurs soyons plus
précis dans la question ça ça rejoint
aussi le questionnement que l'Union
européenne se pose sur l'argent qu'elle
qu'elle envoie qu'est-ce qu'est-ce qu'on
peut dire de la corruption en en
quelques secondes le financement du
Qatar don dont on parle il est monitoré
par les Nations Unies donné avec laaval
d'Israël et normalement il est destiné
au salaire de des fonctionnaires de
l'autorité palistienne restés à Gaza
voilà il y a évidemment des accusations
de pardon de corruption détournement
d'argent dont on est nous incapable de
mesurer l'ampleur mais jusqu'à présent
pas dénoncé par Israël forcément merci
beaucoup eu à tous d'avoir participé à
ce débat je vous dis à bientôt sur
Public Sénat voilà c'est la fin de de
cette émission on vous donne rendez-vous
demain 18h 22h pour un nouveau numéro de
Science Publique et puis Noez que
l'ancien ministre de l'Intérieur député
européens LR Briss ortefeu sera l'invité
de la matinale Dorian Mancini demain
matin